[Music]
let's talk about legit very funny show
your you're acting with George Lazenby
yes legendary actor because he played
James Bond once in one yeah he actually
got contracted to do seven James Bond
films right this isn't like the late say
this is like 1969 yeah and Sean Connery
just think James Bond was asking for
more money and then they said stuff it
will just get the best looking guy on
earth and George was the number one male
model in the planet so they got George
the movie and then he's management told
him that this bond thing is not gonna
carry on very long I would get out of
that contract as quickly as possible
yeah it's a it's a famously bad decision
yeah and so George now plays my dad in
my TV show now the great thing about
George was he was the best looking man
in the world in 1969 and back then women
didn't really get as many rights as
maybe they should have and he's a bit of
a relic at that time I can I swear in
this story are gonna swear a little boy
yeah sure why not so I'm the first day I
meet George Lazenby I'm sitting next to
him and I thought I got to ask this
question and I said George you have a
the bongo and George Wayne I'd be easier
to tell you which ones I haven't haven't
and then and then you guys they all come
to the conventions so George hasn't had
sex with these women in their prime
these are six of them in a motel six
with all their headshots around the room
George has got to be the only like not
even Timothy Dalton shows up to the
convention do you think he's the only
bond that goes like yeah and like
Connery isn't going to the conventions
he's somewhere in a two-year old this is
why we're not friends time I see you I'm
gonna remember you
that's the guy who ruined my show good
god man that's is that a swear word the
last word is it's a horrible thing to
say it didn't it when it's followed by
80 year old lovely fellow gentleman you
are Jim